eighty percent of single parent homes
are headed by women ninety percent right
63 of Youth suicides are from single
mother homes ninety percent of
homelessness and runaway children are
from single mother homes 71 of high
school dropouts are from single mother
home 70 of youths in operated
institutions are from single mobile
homes eighty percent of all youths in
prison are from single mother homes 85
of children who show behavioral
disorders are from single mother homes
eighty percent of rapists with anger
problems are from where single mother
homes so I would like to spell says
you're putting your child at every every
statistical disadvantage when you choose
to just be a quote-unquote single mother